hassan diab est déçu mais loin d'être
surpris il a toujours pensé que cette
enquête à laquelle il a refusé de
participer n'avait pour but que de
blanchir le ministère de la justice est
si profond englobe cette console en
firent materials inc
c'est choquant de voir que nos
inquiétudes se sont matérialisés dit il
hassan diab a été extradé en france en
novembre 2014 après plusieurs années de
débats devant les tribunaux la france le
soupçonnait d'être l'auteur d'un
attentat qui a fait quatre morts et 40
blessés dans une synagogue de paris en
1980 il aura finalement passé plus de
trois ans en prison avant d'être libéré
en janvier 2018 lorsque les accusations
contre lui ont été abandonnées faute de
preuves
hassan diab a reproché aux avocats du
ministère de justice d'avoir autorisé
son extradition
malgré l'absence de preuves solides le
ministère fédéral de la justice avait
mandaté l'ancien procureur en chef de
l'ontario marie sigaud pour enquêter sur
les procédures d'extradition
selon le rapport le ministère de la
justice n'a rien à se reprocher
les avocats du ministère ont agi de
manière éthique est conforme tant
vis-à-vis de la loi que des pratiques et
des politiques du service d'entraidé
internationale conclut marie sigaud il
aimait 14 recommandations sur lesquelles
le gouvernement fédéral entend se
pencher
nous allons les étudier nous sommes
favorables à l'homme à l'amélioration du
système et est donc on va prendre ce que
ceux-ci cola est clean on va le prend
très sérieusement les épaules tu
représentes et autres félins au fait
qu'en vérité selon hassan diab
ce rapport est un échec complet en ce
qui concerne la responsabilité et la
transparence de la part du gouvernement
nous n'avons eu aucune réponse à nos
questions dit l'avocat de hassan diab
qui croient que ces recommandations ne
changeront rien hassan diab réclame à
nouveau une enquête publique et soulève
maintenant la possibilité de poursuivre
le gouvernement fédéral ici jean
françois poudrier radio canada ottawa